في عمق قلب الصحراء العربية ،
ستجد
حقل النفط الأكثر إنتاجًا في أبو ظبي والذي
يشكل نصف الطاقة الإنتاجية اليومية لدولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة والتي
تبلغ حوالي 4 ملايين برميل نفط تم
اكتشافه هنا مرة أخرى في عام 1953
مع وصول الصادرات الأولى بعد عقد من الزمان.
الآن
ثالث أكبر منتج لأوبك ، هذا
هو النفط
المربان وهو خام خفيف مع 60 عميلًا
في 30 دولة مع طلب كبير يأتي
من الصين
واليابان وكوريا الجنوبية من هذا اليوم
فصاعدًا ،
ومن المقرر أن يصنع اسمًا أكبر
لنفسه سلطان الجابر الرئيس
التنفيذي للمجموعة  من شركة بترول أبو ظبي الوطنية
أو
أدنوك قاد حملة لنقلها إلى
سوق العقود الآجلة العالمية
حيث يتم تداول أكثر من مليار برميل من
العقود يوميًا ،
يمثل هذا العقد الجديد عرضًا ذا قيمة كبيرة
وسيكون مكسبًا لجميع العملاء المعنيين.
قادر على إدارة مخاطر السوق بشكل أفضل
بينما سيتم إنشاء المزيد من القيمة
للمنتجين ،
وهذا يعني أن خام ميرفون من
الإمارات العربية المتحدة سيأخذ مقعدًا إلى جانب اثنين من
glo  يقيس bal
برنت بحر الشمال وغرب تكساس
الوسيط ،
وهو أول تغيير كبير
في سوق العقود الآجلة للنفط منذ أكثر من ثلاثة عقود
في منطقة توفر حوالي خمس
الإمدادات
اليومية ونصف احتياطيات النفط
المؤكدة يقول المحللون إن الوقت قد حان
للتعرف
على  روابط الطاقة بين الشرق
الأوسط وآسيا التي كانت دائمًا حالة
شاذة أن الشرق الأوسط
هو أكبر منطقة لتصدير النفط في العالم ،
وآسيا هي أكبر منطقة مستوردة للنفط في العالم
، ومع ذلك فقد تم تسعير هذا الخام
بعيدًا عن المعايير المتداولة في
أوروبا وهذا الإطلاق  يجب معالجة هذا
الشذوذ إذا
تم اعتماده على نطاق واسع ، يتم شحن خام ضواحي
عبر خط أنابيب إلى
ميناء فوجيرا الإماراتي في الشرق
الذي يقع جنوب مضيق
هورمز متجاوزًا المخاطر الأمنية عند
نقطة الاختناق
، لا يمكن أن يكون عقد مستقبلي مثل مربان
واسع النطاق  يقول الاستراتيجيون
الليليون إن adnock تبرز في المقدمة
مع تسع شركات نفط دولية
ومتداولين يأملون في بناء نساء  تشارك شركة Tum ، التي
تُعرف باسم ice ،
مع دولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة للتداول على
عقود الجليد الآجلة في أبو ظبي ،
مما يكسر التقاليد الإقليمية كما هو الحال في
المملكة العربية السعودية
التي تحدد سعرًا ثابتًا كل شهر حيث
أن المصدر الأول في العالم
مربان سيتداول في السوق المفتوحة
مع الأسواق العالمية.  برنت المعياري ،
كانت الخطوة الإستراتيجية التي يقودها
adnock الآن في تداول البراميل بحرية
وتشكل حقًا جزءًا من هذا النوع من
التدفق الحر للخام حول العالم
كانت نقطة انعطاف رئيسية ،
وهذا يمثل معلمًا
هامًا في adnock
for ice for  عملائنا
، وبالطبع جميع شركائنا الذين
يلتقون بالاسم الحضري القادم من هذا
المجال ، أصبحوا علامة تجارية
أبعد من أولئك الذين يستوردونها اليوم
جون ديتريوس سي إن إن أبو ظبي